Thoreau once I had to abandon his house
and his land due to radiation from the
Fukushima nuclear power plant accident
now decontamination of the region is in
full swing it's hoped that evacuated
residents will soon return to their
irradiated ghost towns unsay is one of
them but he's hesitant what will he
decide to do
you could add more every time I come to
eat arte I despair I grew up there I
played in the forest with my sisters and
brother hikes would look for edible
plants so when I go there I remember my
childhood and how it used to be called
own what she said for the much today no
don't way this is not the gentle hilly
countryside around Fukushima used to be
considered one of Japan's most beautiful
regions now there are plastic bags
filled with contaminated soil as far as
the eye can see
although eta is about 40 kilometers from
the reactor the nuclear fallout here was
especially high
once I was resettled shortly after the
meltdown his house is on the outskirts
of the village he's now allowed to enter
it again at least four-day visits he's
emptied out his house completely yes the
building is slowly going to wreck and
ruin
gogoat this is the kitchen there's now
several holes in the floor here's the
bathroom
everything's lying all over the place
go go necessity island mother was my
grandfather as a young man he was a
buddhist priest this is my grandmother
this is my mother and my father
this his religious texts it seems II
know I can't read them terminated mmm
but I can't throw them out either from
my income as a farmer yeah my I've also
worked in the mountains driving a
bulldozer I didn't smoke or drink after
work sake I never gamble sake when I
came home I took quite the corridor
Maharani I'd lie down and watch TV I
said I ate ice cream
it's especially delicious when you're
lying down
he owns about two hectares of land until
the disaster he grew vegetables and rice
on it
this old bus has been here forever it
now stores the bags containing all he
once owned my dishes are in here and
here's the futon it's not clear what's
in the bags but if you touch them you
can tell
today on sea is expecting someone from
Greenpeace to measure the radioactivity
levels the environmental organization
has been active in the region ever since
the accident because it's outside the 20
mile exclusion zone the village of ETA
was only evacuated after Greenpeace put
the pressure on
now the organization's nuclear experts
advise people who are supposed to return
officially his house has already been
decontaminated five centimeters of soil
within a radius of 20 meters were
removed and replaced did that really
help reduce radiation levels that's half
sweet Michael Steve it was clean the
levels right behind his house are almost
10 times higher than those the
government classifies as safe the
nuclear experts explained to him that
the forest behind his plot of land can't
be decontaminated and the rain
repeatedly washes the radioactivity out
of the woodland back toward his house
given this amount of radiation and being
forced back to yes
incise fears have been confirmed
the redzone the actual exclusion zone
isn't far from EU Tata
in some places it's still forbidden to
get out of a car without a permit but
the government is doing all it can to
decontaminate the region as quickly as
possible
Tokyo wants more than a hundred thousand
former residents to return to the region
as soon as they can on zai is one of
them
that will save the government and
nuclear power companies damages in the
billions
in Fukushima City there's a Public
Information Center set up by the
Ministry of the Economy Trade and
Industry there it said that fear of
radiation not radiation itself is making
people sick ensign has come here to get
advice the radiation has returned around
my house two to three microsieverts
that's as much as before decontamination
I can't really believe that where is the
house is it a nice one
yes it's a country house in the hills
the head of the information center tries
to reassure Torro unsafe here the levels
right at the surface are very high two
point five five two five and even more
than six micro suits but as soon as you
go back just a small distance the
radioactivity is much lower
on side drives home unconvinced he
received compensation for the
destruction of his farm and he still
gets monthly benefits
the government has provided him with a
small house in dot a it's about 30
kilometers north of EE Tata
most of those who live in this temporary
settlement are former neighbors of his
Hanako at first I thought this is now my
new home it's very cramped but if I
could stay here I would but I have to
leave it's only a temporary solution but
of course it's or do not get denied
until the government plans to tear down
the emergency housing and end
compensation payments as soon as the
decontamination is finished but on-site
is now almost certain that he won't
return to his house and eat you Tata if
it's still contaminated he'd prefer to
make a completely new start elsewhere
Sundin oh gee I'd like some woods and
farmland where I can have some peace
King this hostel that I saw you there
are houses like that on sale on the
coast
yes oh it's a good day well you have a
good view and can plant vegetables walk
or cultivate rice and then sell the
vegetables for pocket money
oh it's good day as a child what's very
poor but he knows he can't afford it on
site visits his family's graves in eat
at a the small Buddhist cemetery is just
a few hundred metres from his old house
Kukui he Emoto thought my youngest
sister my brother father or grandfather
or grandmother I'll come here from time
to time to visit them for the grave day
hidden under I've got some money on the
couch what's happening I'm so sorry for
them well huh calculate because I was
evacuated to a safe place and I had to
leave them back here
Torro Anza hopes his new life will begin
somewhere else
but his heart remains in Itachi